[Música]
nací hipersensible con las emociones a
flor de piel como si estuviese en carne
viva
es decir los estímulos externos e
internos me afectaban muchísimo podía
subir de 0 a 100 en cuestión de segundos
y las emociones las sentía en su máximo
extremo yo no conocía la tristeza sino
la depresión no conocía la rabia sino la
ira profunda no conocía la alegría sino
la euforia máxima y no conocía el miedo
sino el pánico absoluto
así que sentir tanto y de una manera tan
intensa no fue fácil para mí sobre todo
porque las emociones en nuestra sociedad
no están muy bien vistas es más son
incluso como un insulto cuando alguien
le dice es que tú eres muy emocional es
peyorativo como si ser racional fuese
una virtud y ser emocional fuese un
defecto así que crecer en un contexto
tan invalidante no hizo que fuese fácil
para mí
permitirme las emociones eran muy
amenazantes y al mismo tiempo yo no
sabía qué hacer con todo lo que sentía
era demasiado movimiento era demasiado
caos y no tuve ningún módulo en el
colegio que me enseñara sobre
inteligencia
me enseñaron álgebra inglés español pero
nadie nunca me enseñó qué hacer con las
emociones para qué sirven y por qué son
útiles
así que en mi analfabetismo emocional
crecí utilizando una estrategia que
encontré en el camino que como todas las
estrategias sirven en un momento
particular y en un contexto determinado
y nunca son buenas o malas el problema
es cuando la estrategia se perpetúa y se
usa a lo largo del tiempo cuando ya pasó
ese evento amenazante y entonces
terminamos cavando nuestra propia tumba
y eso fue un poco lo que me pasó a mí no
la estrategia que encontré fue
desconectarme es decir disociar me irme
al mundo de la cabeza y desalojar el
cuerpo por algún motivo pensé que se iba
a hacer una muy buena estrategia y bueno
en un momento si lo fue es decir en un
momento me ayudó a refugiarme en los
libros en la academia en la razón ya no
tener que lidiar con esto pero
simplemente a ponerle pausa porque eso
no se iba a ir así que lo que terminó
pasando fue que eventualmente termine
tan atrapada en mi cabeza que terminé
con otro caos aparte del emocional un
caos racional no un caos mental porque
me la pasaba pensando preocupándome por
el futuro divagando hacia el pasado y no
saber muy bien qué hacer con eso
y eso me pasó la cuenta de cobro porque
además generen huecos en mi vida que me
he podido llenar aún porque como decía
platón todo aprendizaje es emocional y
cuando te la pasas pensando la vida y no
viviendo la no puedes almacenar memorias
no las puedes registrar porque uno
registra a través del cuerpo es el
cuerpo el que puede estar ahí en plena
presencia con todos sus sentidos y si tú
te desconectas de tus emociones también
te desconectas de la vida así que me
prometí a mí misma dedicar gran parte de
mi vida a sanar mi caos emocional y
acompañar a los demás a poder transitar
el suyo así que quiero contarles el
descubrimiento que hice que me permitió
comprender y manejar las emociones mejor
hacerme dueña de ellas y utilizarlas
para vivir una vida con propósito
porque las emociones si bien tenemos un
montón de creencias que aprendemos desde
que somos pequeños no necesariamente
implican eso o solo eso es decir a veces
tenemos la creencia de que si sentimos
somos débiles
quien llora es débil quien tiene miedo
no es valiente quien tiene rabia es
errático incluso quien siente mucha
alegría quizás es muy superfluo oa veces
pensamos que las emociones es una
pérdida de tiempo y son improductivas a
veces tenemos esta creencia de que las
emociones implican x oye y así las
emociones quedan atrapadas en un sistema
de creencias que hace que nosotros
aprendamos a sobrevivir frente a estas
emociones como lo hacemos intentamos
huir o luchar contra las emociones como
vimos bueno a través de la comida
excesiva el trabajo incansable sexo
drogas alcohol televisión cualquier
mecanismo que me permita a mí decir no
prefiero evitar esto y como luchamos
bueno no sé en qué momento de nuestras
vidas se nos dio por luchar contra la
emoción a través del control es decir
como si pudiéramos controlar lo
incontrolable y porque las emociones son
incontrolables porque son naturales es
un flujo natural de una respuesta innata
frente a un acontecimiento eso qué
quiere decir quiere decir que cuando nos
sucede algo la emoción viene nos envía
un mensaje y una vez escuchamos ese
mensaje
la emoción se va como una ola que viene
y va el problema es cuando luchamos
contra ese mensaje y no no lo permitimos
sentir que ahí se desencadena un patrón
descontrolado como la metáfora del río
el río tiene un agua que tiene un fluir
natural cierto tiene una corriente
natural si le ponemos un dique a corto
plazo ese dique va a permitir que el
agua no corra pero qué va a pasar a
mediano ya largo plazo el agua va a
seguir en su corriente natural y el
dique eventualmente va a tener tanta
presión que se va a reventar y se va a
desbordar y ahí en ese momento cuando se
desborda el dique nosotros lo que
hacemos es corro
que nos servimos para sentir que las
emociones son malas que son peligrosas
cuando realmente no nos estamos dando
cuenta del mecanismo que hay detrás y el
mecanismo que hay detrás es nuestra
participación en cómo llevamos a ese
descontrol la emoción en sí no está mal
el problema es que reprimimos
almacenamos embotellamos y luego en vez
de sentir una emoción sentimos 8
emociones y por supuesto va a ser mucho
más difícil sería muchísimo más fácil
que la tristeza apareciera y
escucharemos su mensaje que es muy
válido porque la tristeza aparece cuando
algo que es valioso para nosotros está
dejando de ser pero como nos da rabia
sentirnos tristes y luego sentimos culpa
por sentir rabia por sentirnos tristes
terminamos en el triple del desgaste por
la triple emoción así que ahí es cuando
empiezan a ver los problemas con
respecto a las emociones y sin huir ni
luchar nos funciona vamos a intentar
apagar que fue un poco lo que me pasó
eso es a lo que yo le llamo el caos
silencioso cuando nos desconectamos
tanto que apagamos nuestro mundo
emocional
y si bien estamos controlados podemos
ser funcionales y podemos sobrevivir
vivimos una vida sin sentido en vacío
porque no nos conectamos con nada no
vivimos de una manera apasionada
entonces de alguna de otra forma las
emociones tienen una cantidad de
mensajes importantísimos las emociones
son la base de lo que somos el propósito
de una emoción es guiar a la acción
movilizarnos a la acción es decir el
guión emoción movimiento las emociones
son el movimiento de la vida cuando nos
prohibimos ese movimiento es cuando
estamos muertos en vida y como decía la
neurona tomista volts tyler somos
criaturas sintientes que piensan no
somos criaturas pensantes que sienten
biológicamente la prelación la tiene
nuestra emoción no la razón eso qué
quiere decir quiere decir que si yo
estoy dictando esta conferencia y de
repente aparece una mancha gris con una
cola gigantesca lo primero que yo voy a
hacer es moverme a través de la emoción
del miedo
y luego es que mi cabeza va a decir a
marca ok tranquila es un ratón porque si
yo pienso primero quizás el depredador
me va a atacar en un contexto
supervivencia no así que la emoción va a
ir primero en términos adaptativos y la
emoción tiene una función valorativa
importantísima porque detrás de cada
emoción hay un valor que está siendo
aclamado es decir las emociones son el
faro de lo valioso me gustaría que
hiciéramos un ejercicio juntos porque
estoy segura que ustedes saben más de
emociones de lo que se imaginan porque
están aquí adentro son innatas
quiero que se imaginen a una persona que
es muy especial para ustedes con quien
tienen un vínculo profundo vale y ahora
quiero que se imaginen que esa persona
la van a ver a través de una gran
vitrina y van a ver que hay dos personas
que están corriendo detrás de ella como
si escondieron detrás algo y ustedes
sienten que su persona querida corre
riesgo está siendo amenazada está en
peligro algo le van a hacer que sienten
porque el miedo es una emoción que
aparece cuando algo valioso para
nosotros corre riesgo o está en peligro
si esa persona que es importante para
ustedes de repente estas dos personas
que vienen de atrás ya están ahí frente
a ella y la están atacando agrediendo
violentando o trasgrediendo que sienten
porque la rabia es una emoción que
indica que algo valioso para nosotros
está siendo atropellado aniquilado
violentado
y si esa misma persona ya no está
corriendo su vida peligro y tampoco está
siendo violentada sino que por alguna
causa natural de la vida está dejando de
ser es decir se está desvaneciendo la
relación ya no se está dando y la
extraña en un montón bueno pues eso
quiere decir quizás que aparece la
tristeza porque la tristeza es una
emoción que dice que algo valioso para
nosotros está dejando de ser no puede
ser se está perdiendo y si esa persona
que está ahí frente a ustedes en todo su
esplendor pueden ustedes abrazarla
sentirla verla haciendo su mejor versión
que sienten porque si aparece la alegría
o alguno de sus derivados quiere decir
que algo valioso para nosotros está allí
que lo podemos palpar y agarrar así que
las emociones como se pueden dar cuenta
tienen un significado importantísimo
porque detrás de ellas quiere decir que
una persona una acción un objeto o una
circunstancia es importante para
nosotras y miramos la posibilidad de
sentir corremos el gran riesgo de no
vivir una vida con sentido el problema
es que sentir no es para cualquiera no
requiere valentía arrojo porque te
expone te pone vulnerable hace que
tengas que abrir al mundo y poder decir
esto es lo que yo siento esta es mi
causa este soy yo y eso implica pagar
algunos precios por supuesto y no me
malinterpretes no yo no estoy diciendo
que sentir quiere decir actuar no son
sinónimos no tenemos que dejarnos llevar
por todo lo que sentimos por supuesto
que no entre la emoción y la acción hay
un espacio de tiempo que viktor frankl
solía decir que es el margen de libertad
humana entre el estímulo y la respuesta
en ese espacio ahí podemos elegir qué
hacer con lo que sentimos y ahí es
cuando ganamos mayor propiedad y
libertad sobre la emoción así que bueno
quedamos frente a una disyuntiva señoras
y señores frente a dos realidades por un
lado si nos sentimos no vivimos no
porque si estamos cerrados para no
sentir como amamos cómo nos conectamos
con lo valioso como nos dirigimos hacia
un lugar con sentido y propósito como
nos vinculamos llamamos pero si nos
abrimos eso implica
quedamos muy expuestos y corremos muchos
riesgos
y bueno todo en la vida implica un
riesgo y uno tiene que elegir qué riesgo
quiere tomar así que si tú
definitivamente no quieres sentir porque
no quieres ser vulnerable pues tendrás
que renunciar a la posibilidad de amar y
de ser amado de vincular te intimar con
otras personas y de vivir una vida plena
y con sentido pero si tú quieres amar y
ser amado vivir una vida plena y con
sentido y vincular te intimar con otros
vas a tener que levantarte de esa silla
e ir por lo valioso así que quizás
puedes arrancar por un pequeño paso y es
cuestión ante las creencias que tienes
sobre lo que implica sentir y abrir un
espacio en tu cuerpo a la emoción un
lugar de honor ya que ella te permite
vivir con pasión y acción gracias
[Música]